Here, we tackle backpropagation, the core algorithm behind how neural networks learn.
After a quick recap for where we are, the first thing I'll do is an intuitive walkthrough
for what the algorithm is actually doing, without any reference to the formulas.
Then, for those of you who do want to dive into the math, the next video goes into the
calculus underlying all this.
If you watched the last two videos, or if you're just jumping in with the appropriate
background, you know what a neural network is, and how it feeds forward information.
Here, we're doing the classic example of recognizing handwritten digits, whose pixel
values get fed into the first layer of the network with 784 neurons, and I've been
showing a network with two hidden layers having just 16 neurons each, and an output
layer of 10 neurons, indicating which digit the network is choosing as its answer.
I'm also expecting you to understand gradient descent, as described in the last video, and
how what we mean by learning is that we want to find which weights and biases minimize
a certain cost function.
As a quick reminder, for the cost of a single training example, what you do is take the
output that the network gives, along with the output that you wanted it to give, and
you just add up the squares of the differences between each component.
Doing this for all of your tens of thousands of training examples and averaging the results,
this gives you the total cost of the network.
As if that's not enough to think about, as described in the last video, the thing that
we're looking for is the negative gradient of this cost function, which tells you how
you need to change all of the weights and biases, all of these connections, so as to
most efficiently decrease the cost.
Back propagation, the topic of this video, is an algorithm for computing that crazy complicated
gradient.
And the one idea from the last video that I really want you to hold firmly in your mind
right now, is that because thinking of the gradient vector as a direction in 13,000 dimensions
is, to put it lightly, beyond the scope of our imaginations, there's another way you
can think about it.
The magnitude of each component here is telling you how sensitive the cost function is to
each weight and bias.
For example, let's say you go through the process I'm about to describe, and you compute
the negative gradient, and the component associated with the weight on this edge here comes out
to be 3.2, while the component associated with this edge here comes out as 0.1.
The way you would interpret that is that the cost of the function is 32 times more sensitive
to changes in that first weight.
So if you were to wiggle that value just a little bit, it's going to cause some change
to the cost, and that change is 32 times greater than what the same wiggle to that second weight
would give.
Personally, when I was first learning about back propagation, I think the most confusing
aspect was just the notation, and the index chasing of it all, but once you unwrap what
each part of this algorithm is really doing, each individual effect that it's having
is actually pretty intuitive, it's just that there's a lot of little adjustments getting
layered on top of each other.
So I'm going to start things off here with a complete disregard for the notation, and
just step through those effects that each training example is having on the weights
and biases.
Because the cost function involves averaging a certain cost per example over all the tens
of thousands of training examples, the way that we adjust the weights and biases for
a single gradient descent step also depends on every single example, or rather in principle
it should, but for computational efficiency we're going to do a little trick later to
keep you from needing to hit every single example for every single step.
In other case, right now, all we're going to do is focus our attention on one single
example, this image of a two.
What effect should this one training example have on how the weights and biases get adjusted?
Let's say we're at a point where the network is not well trained yet, so the activations
in the output are going to look pretty random, maybe something like 0.5, 0.8, 0.2, on and
on.
Now we can't directly change those activations, we only have influence on the weights and
biases, but it is helpful to keep track of which adjustments we wish should take place
to that output layer.
And since we want it to classify the image as a two, we want that third value to get
nudged up, while all of the others get nudged down.
Moreover, the sizes of these nudges should be proportional to how far away each current
value is from its target value.
For example, the increase to that number two neurons activation is in a sense more important
than the decrease to the number eight neuron, which is already pretty close to where it
should be.
So zooming in further, let's focus just on this one neuron, the one whose activation
we wish to increase.
Remember, that activation is defined as a certain weighted sum of all of the activations in the
previous layer, plus a bias, which is all then plugged into something like the sigmoid
squishification function, or a relu.
So there are three different avenues that can team up together to help increase that
activation.
You can increase the bias, you can increase the weights, and you can change the activations
from the previous layer.
Focusing just on how the weights should be adjusted, notice how the weights actually
have differing levels of influence.
The connections with the brightest neurons from the preceding layer have the biggest
effect, since those weights are multiplied by larger activation values.
So if you were to increase one of those weights, it actually has a stronger influence on the
ultimate cost function than increasing the weights of connections with dimmer neurons,
at least as far as this one training example is concerned.
Remember, when we talk about gradient descent, we don't just care about whether each component
should get nudged up or down, we care about which ones give you the most bang for your
butt.
This by the way is at least somewhat reminiscent of a theory in neuroscience for how biological
networks of neurons learn, Hebbian theory, often summed up in the phrase, neurons that
fire together, wire together.
Here, the biggest increases to weights, the biggest strengthening of connections, happens
between neurons which are the most active, and the ones which we wish to become more
active.
In a sense, the neurons that are firing while seeing a two, get more strongly linked to
those firing when thinking about a two.
To be clear, I really am not in a position to make statements one way or another about
whether artificial networks of neurons behave anything like biological brains, and this
fires together, wire together idea comes with a couple meaningful asterisks, but taken
as a very loose analogy, I do find it interesting to note.
Anyway, the third way that we can help increase this neuron's activation is by changing all
the activations in the previous layer, namely if everything connected to that digit two
neuron with a positive weight got brighter, and if everything connected with a negative
weight got dimmer, then that digit two neuron would become more active.
And similar to the weight changes, you're going to get the most bang for your buck by
seeking changes that are proportional to the size of the corresponding weights.
Now, of course, we cannot directly influence those activations.
We only have control over the weights and biases.
But just as with the last layer, it's helpful to just keep a note of what those desired
changes are.
But keep in mind, zooming out one step here, this is only what that digit two output neuron
wants.
Remember, we also want all of the other neurons in the last layer to become less active, and
each of those other output neurons has its own thoughts about what should happen to that
second to last layer.
So, the desire of this digit two neuron is added together with the desires of all the
other output neurons for what should happen to this second to last layer.
Again, in proportion to the corresponding weights, and in proportion to how much each
of those neurons needs to change.
This right here is where the idea of propagating backwards comes in.
By adding together all these desired effects, you basically get a list of nudges that you
want to happen to this second to last layer.
And once you have those, you can recursively apply the same process to the relevant weights
and biases that determine those values.
Repeating the same process I just walked through and moving backwards through the network.
And zooming out a bit further, remember that this is all just how a single training example
wishes to nudge each one of those weights and biases.
If we only listened to what that two wanted, the network would ultimately be incentivized
just to classify all images as a two.
So, what you do is you go through this same back prop routine for every other training
example, recording how each of them would like to change the weights and the biases.
And you average together those desired changes.
This collection here of the averaged nudges to each weight and bias is, loosely speaking,
the negative gradient of the cost function referenced in the last video, or at least
something proportional to it.
I say loosely speaking only because I have yet to get quantitatively precise about those
nudges.
But if you understood every change that I just referenced, why some are proportionally
bigger than others, and how they all need to be added together, you understand the mechanics
for what back propagation is actually doing.
By the way, in practice, it takes computers an extremely long time to add up the influence
of every single training example, every single gradient descent step.
So here's what's commonly done instead.
You randomly shuffle your training data and then divide it into a whole bunch of mini
batches, let's say each one having a hundred training examples.
Then you compute a step according to the mini batch.
It's not going to be the actual gradient of the cost function, which depends on all
of the training data, not this tiny subset.
So it's not the most efficient step downhill.
But each mini batch does give you a pretty good approximation, and more importantly,
it gives you a significant computational speedup.
If you were to plot the trajectory of your network under the relevant cost surface, it
would be a little more like a drunk man stumbling aimlessly down a hill, but taking quick steps,
rather than a carefully calculating man determining the exact downhill direction of each step
before taking a very slow and careful step in that direction.
This technique is referred to as stochastic gradient descent.
There's kind of a lot going on here, so let's just sum it up for ourselves, shall we?
Track propagation is the algorithm for determining how a single training example would like to
nudge the weights and biases, not just in terms of whether they should go up or down,
but in terms of what relative proportions to those changes cause the most rapid decrease
to the cost.
A true gradient descent step would involve doing this for all your tens and thousands
of training examples, and averaging the desired changes that you get.
But that's computationally slow, so instead you randomly subdivide the data into these
mini-batches and compute each step with respect to a mini-batch.
Repeatedly going through all of the mini-batches and making these adjustments, you will converge
towards a local minimum of the cost function, which is to say your network is going to end
up doing a really good job on the training examples.
So with all of that said, every line of code that would go into implementing backprop actually
corresponds with something that you have now seen, at least in informal terms.
But sometimes knowing what the math does is only half the battle, and just representing
the damn thing is where it gets all muddled and confusing.
So for those of you who do want to go deeper, the next video goes through the same ideas
that were just presented here, but in terms of the underlying calculus, which should hopefully
make it a little more familiar as you see the topic in other resources.
Before that, one thing worth emphasizing is that for this algorithm to work, and this
goes for all sorts of machine learning beyond just neural networks, you need a lot of training
data.
In our case, one thing that makes handwritten digits such a nice example is that there exists
the MNIST database, with so many examples that have been labeled by humans.
So a common challenge that those of you working in machine learning will be familiar with
is just getting the labeled training data that you actually need, whether that's having
people label tens of thousands of images, or whatever other data type you might be dealing
with.